sie kamen in der nacht und sie hatten
einen räumungsbefehl
laut gerichtsbeschluss müssen 13
arabische familien ihr zuhause verlassen
das war vor gut einer woche der funke
der das pulverfass entzündet hat
sheikh jarrah das arabische viertel am
damaskus tor ist der brennpunkt in ost
jerusalem
die israelis eroberten es im
sechstagekrieg 1967 durften es aber
nicht besiedeln
nun holen die gerichte es haus für haus
zurück für jüdische siedler die alte
besitzansprüche geltend machen können
und die palästinenser soll nun plötzlich
weichen wir sind 14 personen in unserer
familie sieben erwachsene und sieben
kinder
was auch immer geschieht wir gehen hier
nicht weg wenn sie wollen dass wir
verschwinden dann müssen sie uns
umbringen der konflikt war programmiert
die arabischen jugendlichen des viertels
lieferten sich als selbsternannte
verteidiger der umstrittenen häuser
nächtelange scharmützel mit der polizei
die antwortete indem sie die menge immer
wieder mit stinkendem wasser beschossen
angefeuert von national- religiösen
siedlern die bereits in der
nachbarschaft wohnen
das sind unsere häuser und sie wollen
sie kontrollieren und unser land wollen
sie auch übernehmen
sie machen einfach was sie wollen sie
sind vor 50 jahren aus jordanien
gekommen sollen sie doch dahin
zurückgehen wie mohammed will nicht nach
jordanien zurück denn dort kommt sie gar
nicht her
die palästinenserin ist hier in sheikh
jarrah geboren in diesem haus das
bereits ihren eltern gehörte sie
arbeitet als lehrerin an einer
ostjerusalemer schule hat vier kinder
auch ihre familie hat einen
räumungsbescheid bekommen alle die hier
wohnen sind wie eine große familie
wir sind eine sehr enge gemeinschaft das
leben in ihrem viertel sei über die
jahre immer schwieriger geworden nicht
nur die zwangsräumung schwebe als
damoklesschwert über ihnen es sei der
alltägliche streit mit den jüdischen
siedlern der sie um ihre zukunft und die
sicherheit ihrer familie bangen lässt
sie haben eine art synagoge hier gleich
hinter unserem haus und wenn sie ihre
feiertage begehen dann drehen sie die
musik laut auf bis nachts um 34 uhr und
dann trinken sie bier in glasflaschen
und dann kommt es auch vor dass sie
damit nach uns werfen
einmal hat eine flasche meinen vater am
kopf getroffen
auf dem dach des hauses zeigt sich
deutlich wie eng und wie problematisch
das zusammenleben in diesem stadtteil
ist und wie zermürbend der alltägliche
kleinkrieg die jüdischen siedler wohnen
gleich im haus gegenüber
ja die gitter haben sie vor kurzem zu
ihrem schutz vor dem balkon angebracht
dabei sind sie jetzt auch die mit waffen
herumlaufen
die zuspitzung des streits erfolgte im
kalendarisch ungünstigsten moment für
die muslime geht gerade der fastenmonat
ramadan zu ende
ein hochemotionaler zeitpunkt und
gleichzeitig feierten die israelis vor
allem die religiöse rechte dem jerusalem
tag den sieg über die arabischen armeen
und die einnahme der hauptstadt
und so führte der immobilien streit in
der altstadt innerhalb weniger tage zu
raketenangriffen und luftschlägen
und die nächte explodieren in krawall
und das sind nicht nur die jugendlichen
in gaza und in ost-jerusalem die
rebellieren
der aufruhr hat die arabischen israelis
erfasst in der nacht entlud sich ihr
zorn in lud unweit von tel aviv mit dem
angriff auf parkende autos auf geschäfte
und sogar auf eine synagoge diese nacht
war ein alptraum
es war ein richtiger aufstand der
arabischen jugendlichen sie kamen in
massen fackelten ein auto nach dem
anderen ab es war sehr gefährt das
zusammenleben der jüdischen mehrheit mit
der arabischen minderheit war nie
problemlos die arabischen israelis
fühlen sich oft diskriminiert
sympathisieren mit den palästinensern
aber nun scheint das klima nachhaltig
vergiftet
am nachmittag wird unser kamerateam in
lud zeuge die arabische jugendliche
einen jüdischen mitbürger bedrängen und
mit steinen attackieren
ich bin hier nur lang gegangen und diese
kerle haben versucht mich zu steinigen
die haben versucht mich umzubringen weil
ich jude bin die steinewerfer erheben
ihrerseits schwere vorwürfe hier auf dem
handy habe ich den beweis sie bewerfen
uns mit steinen
da sie doch und dann beschimpfen sie
einander und beschuldigen sich
gegenseitig aber keiner wird den anderen
zu